[Music]
I was surprised to learn that you're not
a vegetarian I didn't mean to stereotype
but you know you're an ordained monk
you're from you were raised in India not
a vegetarian I grew up not being a
vegetarian is I'm a vegetarian now oh
you've gone yeah yeah I grew up though
in a North Indian family um coming from
a tribal warrior class where everybody
ate meat and usually lamb or goat so
that's my childhood conditioning but I'm
really at the moment totally a
plant-based guy plant-based yeah gone
that way well you just lost a bunch of
weight I did yes congratulations uh 30
PBS is that correct 20 20 yeah yeah we
can
lie and you and you did that by eating a
bunch of plants and stuff a bunch of
plants I moved in the direction of a
plant-based diet and that's what I do
right now but also
listen to my body and I realize that
people put food in their body only for
two reasons one is they're hungry for
food two is they're hungry for something
else
what well people are hungry for love
people are hungry for compassion Joy
they are hungry
for Spiritual hunger is also a h you
know understand I was hungry for
playfulness so that's why I came to your
show well that's that's a real thrill
for me thank you I like that very much
what is a bigger threat to the for to
this country would you say tobacco big
tobacco or like big uh Big
Mac I think right now the it's a very
interesting situation half the world is
dying of diabetes and obesity and the
other half is dying of malnutrition from
Hunger so we have a great IM balance and
yes the the way we treat animals the way
we industrially produce food uh with
hormones and insecticides and pesticides
and antibiotics and chemicals it's not
only only destroying us it's destroying
the entire ecosystem and it's the
biggest cause of climate change as well
right do you think there's something
karmic about that factory farming and
just not really caring about what we eat
and the response I think every choice is
a karmic uh has a karmic effect I like
that I'm into
[Music]
this